so thanks peter um so i'm gonna tell you
about
uh one of the projects that we have in
our group
uh uh which we did last summer with juan
julie who was a visiting researcher
um and he was also an assistant
professor at cmu and dhiraj nagaraj who
was my intern and he's also a graduate
student at mit
so what we were trying to understand is
how does
what is the exact role of over
parametrization for robustness in neural
network
so let me tell you what the picture i'm
showing here is about
so on the x axis i'm plotting the
dimension or square root of the
dimension so i'm in the machine learning
setting i'm going to be in high
dimension i mean here's the dimension
varies between
something like a hundred and and 5000
something like that
and the blue dots they correspond to
training a
very very large neural network to fit
data in that dimension
and the red dots they correspond to
training a small
neural network to fit the data and what
you see on the y-axis
is how lip sheets is a corresponding
function okay so the
the less slip sheets it is the less
robust it is the higher it is
and you can see the red dot the smaller
network in high dimension they are very
non-robust they are very non-lip sheets
okay
whereas the very small one the blue dots
is it it remains
basically constant deliciousness as the
dimension varies
so what we wanted to do in this project
is to try to put this phenomenon
on solid mathematical foundations
so here is what we did
let me walk you through this so i'm
going to introduce
a couple of notations and really what
the paper is about
is a conjecture and i will tell you some
of the things that we know about this
conjecture
so let me start with the definition so
first of all we're only gonna
be talking about two layers neural
network two layers neural network means
there is one hidden layer
so what is a two-layer neural network it
takes as input
a point x in rd in the dimension of
space and it outputs the following
number
so we're gonna have k neurons what each
neuron does is that it first computes an
affine function so what is the affine
function it's parameterized by a vector
wl
and an offset bias bl it computes wl dot
x plus bl that's what the alpha function
of the else neuron does
then it applies an only narrative side
so psi
is some fixed non-linearity from the
real line to the real line
okay so you can think of the rectified
linear unit or the hyperbolic tangent
or whatever you want and so that's the
output of the else neuron okay so the
non-linearity applied to the alpha
function
and then the neural network recombines
all these outputs linearly so it does
the sum for l equals 1 to k
and we combine them with weights a l
okay
and i'm going to denote this function
class f k
of psi okay so this is a function that
can be expressed as a k
neurons neural network with nonlinearity
psi
now we're going to be in a machine
learning setting what does it mean
we're going to have a training set a set
of points x i y i
x i is the input y is the output and for
normalization purposes i'm going to
assume the x
i's are on the unit sphere they have
unit norm
and the y i i'm just going to consider
binary classification we can talk about
more general things
so it's just a sign either a minus one
or a plus one
and i have n points in uh in the
dimensional space
and for this talk i'm going to assume
that this data is random uniformly
random
we can also discuss about this
assumption but for now for this talk
everything is uniformly random so
whenever i say something holds
with high probability i mean with high
probability with respect to the sampling
of the data set
and i'm not going to precise whether
it's you know exponentially large
probability polynomially large
it's not too important so the first
thing that i want you to know or
remember
is this uh serum uh from you know 30
years ago
by eric baum which says the following so
the first question you might want to ask
is
can i find a neural network that fits my
data let's say that fits it exactly okay
so what it means is does there exist f
in
fk of psi such that f x i is equal to y
i for any i in one to f and what eric
baum
showed is that this will be true this
will happen
as long as the number of degrees of
freedom of your function class which is
k
times d is larger than the number of
equations you're trying to fit
okay so from your linear algebra in
tradition it makes a lot of sense
uh but but here it's a it's a little bit
different so
again y is k times d the number of
degrees of freedom i have k neurons
each neuron is described by d plus two
points okay the
uh the vector the the bias and the
recombination weights okay so if k
times d plus two is much larger than n
then you can find a function that fits
exactly the point very good perfectly
understood
now here is the question that we want to
ask okay so this is
in a sense this is the main contribution
of the work the question we want to ask
is
what if in addition of these kind of
linear equations
okay by linear i mean they are linear in
the function
in f okay in the estimation of uh they
are linear functional
of the function f they are just
evaluation so
in addition to this n linear equation
what if we add also the very very
non-linear equation
that the lipschitz constant should be
small
lips is concerned small means that we
want our neural network to be robust we
want that
if we input x and we get f of x then if
we input some you know
x tier which is very close to x then f x
t
should be very close to f of x okay so
it's a lipschitzness is very directly a
notion of robustness
and i didn't say it but i'm always in
this talk i'm assuming that n
as the number of data points is
polynomial in the dimension so if you
take random points on the sphere you
know every point is far from each other
so it means that there exists an
interpolation which is smooth okay
that's very very easy to see
so there exists a function you know
which is not necessarily in fk or psi
which is constant lip sheets and which
fits perfectly the data
and the question we ask is does there
also exist such a function in fk of
psi and what's easy to see
is that yes the answer is yes if
k is larger than n okay so if you have
more
neurons and number of data points then
you can actually
fit smoothly your data points and this
is easy to see because
what you know what is going to be a
smooth interpolation of your data point
well you just want to have a small bump
around each data point
and you can mimic each bump like this
with one neuron or with a constant
number of neurons
okay so it's easy to see that when the
number of neurons is larger than n
you can do it mostly and we said that
when the number
of neurons is larger than n over d
that's already enough to fit so this k
larger than n it's another
parametrization by a fractal d
okay so it's a huge overparametrization
and the question is
do you need this huge parametrization or
is there a smarter way
to interpolate smoothly with neural
network and
the key point is our conjecture so our
conjecture says that
basically you cannot do better than than
the trivial thing k larger than n
and that over parametrization is
absolutely necessary for robustness
so mathematically what we say is there
exists
if if there exists a func um if there
exists a function
f in f k of psi which interpolates your
data such that f
x is equal to y then necessarily it must
be that the lipschitz constant let's say
even restricted to the sphere but you
can just think about the lymph's
constant on the whole space
is larger than square root n over k
so let's pass this larger than square
root of number k it means that
if you want the ellipse constant to be o
of one
k needs to be larger than m okay on the
other end if you are the optimal size
regime if k is like
n over d then necessarily the liches
constant is like square root d
so this conjecture fully justifies the
picture we add
okay so i have two minutes now so let me
just in two minutes tell you the
three results that we know the partial
results so we have only three partial
results
the first one is that this conjecture is
actually true
if instead of the lich is constant you
compute a certain upper bound
on the lymph's constant which we call
the proxy lipids constant
which is basically the the product of
all the lipsticks constants
of the different ingredient of the
neural network so the you know the first
layer is a
is a certainly affine map then the
second layer is a certain linear
function and in between
there is a non-linearity so the least
constant of the whole thing
by the chain rule is upper bounded by
the product of the three difference
constant
so if you look at the product of this
ellipse constant then this is larger
than square root of k
we only know how to prove this for when
there is no bias term
another thing that we know the second
result is the lynch's constant is larger
than it's called d over k for rectified
linear unit networks with no bias
this is a completely different
phenomenon you know it looks like oh
it's pretty good you know
instead of scored and over k you get
squared but let me say it's completely
different because it's only interesting
when k is less than d
meaning that your neurons don't even
span the whole space
so it's a it's an under complete
scenario and the
most interesting result is the third one
when the
nonlinearity is a polynomial of degree p
then we can actually prove the
conjecture and it's a nice proof which
is related to
deep mathematics about tensors but we
can only prove it in the case where
n is as large as possible for such a psi
meaning that n is of order d to the p
and when k
the number of neurons is as small as
possible meaning that k is like d to the
p minus one
and n over d so in this extreme regime
then we can prove the conjecture
and proving it for instance for other k
is related to very very
difficult and interesting mathematics
about low rank tensors that i don't have
time to get into
um i think that's all i wanted to say
thanks